yeah if you see me come say what's up
take a picture I'll [__] follow you
on Instagram bu [__] Marty goes hard
dude and here's why I don't follow
everyone in Instagram and people have
asked me that you ready three separate
times I have met people and taken
pictures with them you know how many
people have used the picture with me and
them to sell packs he says he your homie
he's got packs he has a picture with you
you know what if I was some dude in the
midwest I followed me and I went yo oh
you do know you have a picture with him
all right what's up how much for the QP
all right you're going to ship it cuz
Thomas I know is not a piece of [__] man
now I'm a piece [__] so I don't follow
everyone I don't follow people that have
no profile pictures or posts because the
next post just be a swasa or a dick and
then I'm following somebody that just
posts a dick and has racial [__] you
have to think about this this is a real
thing I love how when we think of
horrible [__] it's always like dick or
racist there the two worst things in the
world like don't show me no dick don't
show me no
swash evil
gross both evil and gross depending on
the situation